[Music]
hey what do you guys uh think about
tarot card reading I think it's the
future oh totally true I
love wait you talk about the diner yeah
I was like what the know caros had cards
T I heard caros cuz I love caros see I
heard caros too I think you're pulling
my Johnson what do you guys love about
Kos the $ the $15 steak and eggs it's a
good deal carot cards it's $15 we're
steaking eggs sirlo maybe just for fun
we could bring it back let's bring it
back you said Carol card I said terot
you here like an idiot I think ter cards
are I was thinking tarot
Boba nice too I love how tarot cards
could tell me everything about myself
that I didn't know a tar everything and
they could they could they could
basically let me know what my future is
going to be so I could prepare I use it
all the time has it been right you
really use it all the time when was the
last time you got tarot reading you look
like you go to tarot readings uh you
look like you give
them no there's a there's a YouTube
channel and this lady tells you your ter
you get YouTube ter reading replay the
video and see if she says the same thing
that be crazy usually does was crazy I
watch same video did you give me the
same Destiny as yours really yeah [__]
man but don't they do it for like
different signs or some [__] like if
you're like I don't know they have so
many weird descriptors of you got to be
aquarious rising yeah like zodiac and
then the moon and then the time of day
like there's so many different
descriptors love it dude but I feel like
they just uh give you a general thing
cuz like they'll have like a death card
right and it'll be but death is not
supposed to be a bad thing I pull the
death card twice they you get the Grim
Reaper and they're like oh it's not bad
it's not bad it's it just means you know
there's a a new yeah a new uh age for
you that's coming yeah they like
something in your life is going to die
but that also means something else is
going to be reborn and then you walk out
the door and then they're like holy [__]
that fool's dying yeah but I feel like a
lot of tarot cards is is like that it's
like very middle of the road and then
it's like you could you could take it
any way you want they don't say [__] my
question is why are [__] so
susceptible to tell cuz it's literally
about how you feel that and horoscopes
and [__] y they love it and
they need validation I had ex went to a
psychic like every day I was like I
don't know if she's going to love me
today not weekly like monthly probably
does she have
amethysts it was just weird blue
crystals but she like my psychi said
something weird today and I'm like like
what she's like she goes my my psychi
said who's this brown guy in her
life rid of him really p is racist yeah
she goes I see a Brown guy and we like
him he's good guy and he's going to be
in your life forever but maybe not as
your lover but he will be in your life
forever and I'm like as a guy in a new
relationship you're just like I don't
know how to play this yeah oh yeah
that's what do you say you know and I'm
like and she she believes in a lot of
the stuff she says so now I'm like okay
so our our relationships be destined by
what this lady says and you're not with
her right so she was right she was right
yeah are you still in her life though or
is this like you haven't talked to her a
long time one way or another I guess
we're in the same industry we're in the
same thing and when we see each other
it's like she'd be randomly having um
inside jokes from our relationship which
is weird sometimes her husband's sitting
in the her husband's sitting in the room
and we'll have our inside jokes and
we'll just look at each other and then
you said her husband's in the room yeah
like she's fully imagine if they're not
that inside she's like babe you're
needed on set babe
what if you weren't the brown guy though
what if she had a favorite taco
restaurant and it was a Mexican dude
yeah you always see the positive and
everything and then the the psychic
positive is a good word right the
psychic saw the taco man and she goes
there's a brown guy that's in your life
you're not going to be in a relationship
but you're always going to love him be
with him I think you could apply that to
all of our
lives there's going to be a brown guy
that we're all going to be not in a
relationship with but it's life America
yeah so I think that works for everybody
we all got a brown guy right yeah I got
a couple brown guys you got a brown Guy
Brian might be my brown guy you wear a
brown guy and I'm like what do you mean
I've never going to see the black one
dude I'm always going to be a brown I'm
only going to have one brown guy that's
all I say have you guys ever done a
tower reading like a real one like when
you go to a crystal ball lady I don't do
that [__] I had I had some guy do it to
us at a bar once he's like I read tarot
cards no you go to real one and I was
like oh okay he's like you want a
reading and I was like No And my friend
was like I'll do one and I was like
great now we got to [__] hang out
with this guy for a little bit I I got a
close friend who's a who's a witch in
training like they go to school
Apprentice uh yeah like an apprentice no
it's not a special school but it's like
a like a small community of other
witches that like accept them into like
their their second site I know people
that do that stuff they what can they do
that's not human
what does a witch do I think they're
just like almost like a a dimensional
empaths what does that mean sense and
feel energy and they're susceptible to
understanding things like a
microwave my [__] microwave is an
interdimensional impath too [__] heat
my potato in a way I don't know
how what about my air fryer explain that
bud I know witchcraft it's all black
magic and I don't want to hear this it's
just a confectioner of it I don't want
to hear that put a paper towel over so
the oil doesn't splatter
everywhere how does my air fryer cook
that
good me that I made a prime rib on the
air fryer air fryer stuff now talk about
ter never get to this article but yes
[__] tell about the Terra card the
[__] Terra the Terra card it talks
about how like uh witchcrafts and and
conventional ovens and air fryers
according to Pennsylvania law fortune
telling is a crime good so there's lock
them up there's this
one uh witch I believe uh is the right
way to say it who was practicing
witchcraft there giving tarot card
readings and Fortune tellings to
different people for for multiple years
started getting a little bit popular on
like Tik Tok and stuff like that but uh
one day police officers knock on her
door and it's like yo this shit's
illegal and they're trying to shut her
down she posts about on Tik Tok and
everybody gets all pissed and stuff
started commotion because they're like
my air fryer Cooks good and I don't
understand how yeah exactly air friers
are pretty they have a pretty big fan
base nowadays air friers do have a
really big fan base well she didn't see
the cops coming so how much of a psychic
isue
true you can always throw that in her
face she never read her own [__] yeah
you guys ever punch a psychic and be
like you didn't see that [__] coming
yeah I kind of want to now do you think
they go oh yes yes I did actually don't
be like try to recover I read too cards
man I saw this coming actuallyit they're
like it's just like my dream I feel
think that's the only way to pull it off
like if the cops knock at your door and
she's like I was expecting you yeah just
to try to freak out the cops that's what
I said I would do if I was a psychic I
would just stand outside my own door and
when people walk by i' would go I knew
you when getting
come apparently uh fortune telling
related arts are illegal in Pennsylvania
punishable by 6 to 12 months in jail and
a $2500 fine they're pretty strict about
that of course in Pennsylvania they burn
them at the state throw these scam
artists
away what about your your mom's friend
she they scam my mom every day that's
time traveling that's different
different different related arts oh yeah
that might be related you're right my
mom gets scammed and she loves it
they're SpaceTime SpaceTime Buddhists I
keep telling her to stop going back and
she always goes back she always calls
them getting scammed all the [__]
time you know the real ones though the
real ones they they don't mix money and
business with their Powers cuz realize
realize
realize they'll be like they'll be like
hey uh so you're going to want to um not
be here on July 14th and then just do
this and and they'll tell you to be like
I don't want any money they see some
[__] I don't want any money because
you're going to
die you know uh uh Hannah's got crazy
Powers though like like that uh like she
just like has weird visions and [__] and
dreams and stuff so like one of them
like premonitions or Second Sight she
always knows like what kind of [__] I
just think she has like like that
female's Intuition or whatever it's just
weird because uh planetary alignment
she's nailed every single gender for
within our friend group before they even
announced it so she'd be like oh she's
going to have a boy she'll be like she's
been right so far she just she's just
hella good at heads or tails yeah yeah
but it could be boy or girl but she's
like 5050
chance before he take her to [__] the
casinos before before taica uh had his
seizure right she had a dream about him
falling down and everyone worried and
she goes ta's TAA I don't know if we
told you this but they were like we were
in a group right and then taer had a
seizure another thing his first seizure
ever what do you mean that's what I'm
saying he told you about this he told me
after he told me after oh well that's a
good
old don't do that that face dude you
can't do that face you can't do that
face dude that's true cuz the vision
needs to share something fight on
December 2nd conclusion after [__] the
vision I think it was a it was a Sher or
something but it was it was it was
specific and it was taica it was oh I
see I see another one this is a this is
a bigger trip so a year before the Maui
fire right she's like um we were in
Hawaii and then she's like yeah I just
had a crazy dream where it was a flood
like Hawaii had a tsunami of fire in
Hawaii and then she's like and everyone
was running up the mountains and running
everywhere and then we were just trapped
in like a huge fiery tsunami well that's
[__] cuz that's not what happened it
was a space laser [__] it was clearly a
space ler and then she's like yeah that
dream was so crazy and then I'm and then
the Lina fire happens and then it's like
that's pretty [__] nuts though [__]
yeah did she tell anybody though that
could do something about it well she was
I think what I think what okay that's
too much I think where where it was
missed is that the vision happened on
waho rather than Maui so she she missed
she's not a good witch was it a wave of
Fire Hits a Wahu now later right I think
the Wi-Fi was down yeah so it was like
dang she goes yeah it was like a flood
but fire flood it hit W is that what she
no it was yeah it was like um it was
where we were live where it's where we
live in aahu and she goes but like like
hella people were running and all that
and then the Lina fire do you ever get
scared of Hannah for that type of [__]
no it's kind of
helpful and then she'll see ghosts and
[__] too she'll see ghost yeah if I knew
which I would just like randomly do
karate moves around him yeah so they
just know not to [__] with me yeah
[__] none of those witchcraft over
here yeah like back sweep a teddy bear
just let it go flying and just look at
the witch
like you know what I don't see
I hear a lot of these ladies talking
about being witches right yeah I don't
see many Wizards that's true Gandalf no
but like
guys make hey hey bro chill why are
[__] susceptible well maybe in the
Witchcraft industry they got canceled a
long time ago you know cuz I I feel like
the woman's Monopoly patriarchy of
wizards cuz whenever you think of Shaman
or like a druid or someone or like you
think of like a like [__] Merlin or
like a like a no all the Wizards and
warlocks wear [__] pillowcases cuz
those guys probably have blue collared
jobs they're Carpenters they're probably
working yeah they don't got time for
that they got to work overtime cuz the
[__] power line went down they're
like I can't [__] spread my [__]
fairy dust this week wife tell him I had
a dream about a power line going
down what did she telling it's medicine
it's medicine man not Medicine Woman all
right all right dude so from now on you
got to [__] tell us Hannah's dream
okay I will right when it happen when it
happen then we got to say it in video
text us in the group the video is going
to be uploaded after the incident so you
have to do something with the info you
can't wait for it to happen and go oh
that's the thing you have to like move
out of Hawaii cuz you think it's going
to catch fire I didn't know that I just
thought it was crazy but from now on
since she has a track record that seems
pretty good now we got to restart
recording it was the wrong Island but
still that's pretty crazy still and it
wouldn't be one time she'd have it over
and over she goes like had the same
Nightmare and I had the same nightmare
it would be like for a week and it then
so we could especially if it's
consistent like that now we know the
pattern okay now we see she's like a
space later hits Pasadena you're like
what what about what about tail toown
Green Street or uh
[Music]
Colorado